Mais c'était comme si nous ne savions plus comment avancer.
Nous avons avancé malgré tout
et c'est l'image que nous avons publié après l'élection de Donald Trump
et lors de la marche des femmes
dans tous le pays.
Durant ces 24 années,
j'ai vu des milliers d'images voir le jour semaine après semaine.
On me demande souvent quelle est ma préférée
mais je n'arrive pas à en choisir une
parce que ce dont je suis le plus fière,
c'est de la manière dont ces images diffèrent l'une de l'autre.
Et c'est dû au talent et à la diversité
de tous les artistes qui ont contribué.
À présent, eh bien,
nous sommes détenus par la Russie
donc —
(Rires)
Dans une interprétation de Barry Blitt ici,
Eustace s'est transformé en Eustace Vladimirovich Tilley.
Et le papillon n'est rien d'autre qu'un Donald Trump sidéré,
battant ses ailes,
et se demandant comment contrôler l'effet papillon.
Le fameux logo dessiné par Rae Irvin en 1925
est à présent en cyrillique.
Ce qui m'enthousiasme vraiment avec notre époque,
c'est la façon dont...
Vous savez, la liberté de la presse est essentielle à notre démocratie.
Nous pouvons voir, du sublime au ridicule,
que les artistes peuvent capturer l'air du temps
de la façon qu'un artiste,
simplement armé d'encre de chine et d'aquarelle,
peut capturer et entrer dans le dialogue culturel.
Ces artistes sont placés au centre de cette culture
et je pense que c'est exactement là où ils doivent se trouver.
Parce que ce dont nous avons besoin de nos jours, c'est d'un bon dessin.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)